he's living in the shadows in an
unfamiliar world a young man on the run
in Western Europe but Arthur can't go
home because he is Chechen and he's gay
at the summer snows nice the most which
he plays historical weight came to
theater much more diverse than we did
when it was a technical issue
it doesn't mean good size he tried to
hide his sexuality in Chechnya but the
police found out and tried to take him
away he says he missed them by just a
few minutes and knows what would happen
if he returned Lavinia was at Des Moines
as the Thomas Smith it applies to any
more
the Thomas the mayor would see Nikki to
signify telephonist as Ali still is
little brother to study girls to yogi to
the other schools will cross the Smith
threatened by family members and the
police dozens of men have fled from
Chechnya in the past few months some
head north to cities like Moscow and st.
Petersburg but it's not safe to stay in
Russia the Arthur's relatives told him
they'd hunt him down a question of Honor
they said anyone would make you will be
punished
yes they kept it a good enough way Tomas
we know you know he really knows that
you have no suspicion you Tom Lieber
or he's provided the poles me at least
this homophobic attacks in Russia are
all too common this victim was targeted
by men in masks just a few months ago
but in Chechnya the authorities have
gone further
it's thought imprisoning torturing and
murdering gay men activists are trying
to get dozens of Chechens out of the
country
approaching more than 20 Western
embassies for help but they've received
little in the way of assistance done
what pure focus emotion promote Kodama
governor's to Mostafavi the meeting do
the money yet
what the option mr. Dodson his
technician strongly he passed my
analysis biscayne is that a crime that
do tingled music we met Maxime now
hiding in a Moscow suburb he has endured
two weeks of torture electrocuted and
beaten in a Chechen jail he says and he
can see no way out but puffs must warm
up I'll oppose the on his neck
means I see I miss collage data click
call button Scott this is the genuine he
technology with Naga a brat entire
genome Nieto
European astronomers be shot so the TV's
the British Foreign Secretary has said
what is happening in Chechnya is
outrageous the European Union has
expressed
deep concern yes this took a slope I
just kicked a few skied used to mean you
eaten I took Maxim's concerns to top
officials from Russia and the European
Union there are more than 30 members of
the gay community from Chechnya
currently in hiding in Russia should the
European Union or individual states from
the European Union come up with a plan
with a rescue plan to facilitate their
exit we believe that the Russian
Federation the authorities of the
country
hold the primary responsibility of
protecting their citizens rights ms
mogherini here saying it's up to russia
to sort the problem out you also use
kotoba her counterpart however waived
the allegations away informatica to
repeated Alaba its Venini become
weakened Chittenden it easily
Arthur says the facts are clear to him
that's why he applied for asylum in the
EU four months ago but there's been no
progress with his case his apostasy is
banished at our dinner Domino to the
custom you know to the diadem a dramatic
result I read my Twitter dominionist
Padma McDaniel Woodstock research just a
static research
the ordeal isn't over and Arthur's still
looking for a home John sparks Sky News